في ابرز التطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
قال الجيش الاوكراني وان دفاعاته الجويه
اعترضت فجر اليوم 34 طائره مسيره من نوع
شاهد من اصل 44 اطلقها الروس باتجاه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه الجيش الاوكراني الى
ان دفاعاته الجويه اسقطت ست طائرات
استطلاع الروسيه من نوع اورلاند وزال
وسوبر كامان اضاف ان قواته خاضت اكثر من
عشرين اشتباكا مع القوات الروسيه على
مختلف جبهات القتال في الساعات القليله
الماضيه وكشف ان القوات الروسيه نفذت 57
غاره جويه وخمسين هجوما صاروخيا لافتا الى
ان قواته نجحت في صد هجمات الروسيه في
مقاطعه دنيا واوضح الجيش الاوكراني انه
يواصل الهجوم في محور زبارودجا الجنوبي
باتجاه مدينه
البلاد قالت الاداره العسكريه ان شخصين
قتل واصيب ثلاثه في قصف روسي واضافه
الاداره ان المقاطعه تتعرضت امس الى اكثر
من 100 هجوم اطلقت خلالها القوات الروسيه
نحو 600 قذيفه وصواريخ جراد وطائرات مسيره
وكشفت ان مدينه خرسون تعرضت الى هجوم نابث
33 قذيفه سقط بعضها وسط المدينه ما تسبب
في الحاق اضرار بالمباني والابنيه التحتيه
جنوبا ايضا قريه الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه ان القوات الروسيه
نفذت 148 هجوما خلال الساعات الاخرى ان
الهجوم الروسيه استهدف 27 بلده قريبه من
خط المواجهه حيث سجل سقوط 125 قذيفه في
هذه البلدات ووفقا للاداره العسكريه فيزا
فان الهجمات الروسيه اسفلت عن اصابه شخص
بجروح وتعرض 25 مبنى ومنشاه خاصه وعامه
للتدمير
ينضم الينا من زبالوجيا مراسل جزيره الياس
كرام الياس ابرز ما سجل اليوم في زبالوجيا
وايضا عن تحديثات اليوميه لهيئه الاركان
نعمل جديد هو ما يؤكده الجيش الاوكراني
فداء حول التقدم الذي احرزته القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه على محور
تحديدا عند بلده اودرا ديفيكا وكذلك شوميز
الى المنطقه الجنوبيه من باخموت الجيش
الاوكراني يقول بان قواته تقدمت فئتين
البلدتين هذا بالاضافه الى ما كان اعلنه
الجيش الاوكراني في الاسبوع الماضي عن
تمكنه من اعاده السيطره على بلدتيك لشيفكا
واندريفيكا على هذا المحور قبل قليل نشر
الجيش الاوكراني صورا جويه من الداخموت
ومن بلده كليشيفكا وقد اظهرت هذه الصور
فدا حقيقه دمارا هائلا تعرضت له باق موت
واكليشيفكا هذه المدينه باخمت مدينه كبيره
في الدومباس احيلت الى دمار كبير كما يبدو
بسبب المعارك الدائره حولها
اخرها في الشهور الاخيره الدمار الكبير
والمعارك التي تخلفها
القتال يخلفه القتال بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه على هذا المحور هو كبير
للغايه بحيث ان القتال يترك حقيقه ارضا
محروقه
وبلدات ومدن مدمره بالكامل لكن الواضح بان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه نجحت كما يبدو
في توسيع دائره النيران حول ضخمه بعد ان
تركزت في الاسابيع الماضيه في المناطق
الشماليه وهذا ما يعني بان نيران القوات
المسلحه الروسيه تشتت الان الى محاور
الوسط والجنوب حول ضخمه صحيح بان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت ربما بعيده المنال عن
تحقيق نصر في استعاده
لكنها كما اشرنا وسعت دائره النيران وقالت
بان الخط الرئيس بين جوورليفكا وضخموت
الذي يعد خط من القوات المسلحه الروسيه من
جهه الجنوب بات ايضا هو تحت نيران القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه على محور الجنوب هنا
في زبروجيا وهو المحور الاهم والاكبر في
الهجوم المعاكس فدى القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه هجومها بطيء في هذا المحور وهي
تقول بانها صدت محاوله من جانب القوات
الروسيه بالامس من اجل اعاده السيطره على
ما فقدته من مواقع في بلده رابوتين هذه
البلده التي تتحدث القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه لانها تسيطر عليها منذ اكثر من
شهر لكن من الواضح بان المعارك ما زالت
دائره حولها وهذا يؤكد بان محور
الرابوتين ما زال يشهد قتالا عنيفا وشرسا
من بين الطرفين
الخطوط الدفاعيه للقوات الروسيه لم تنهر
بعد وكذلك القوات
الاوكرانيه لا تستطيع كما يبدو احراز
اختراق كبير في هذا محور تطلعاتها كما
يقول المراقبون العسكريون وقياده هذا
المحور بانهم يريدون الوصول الى توكماك
جنوبا لتسهيل حركتهم واندفاعهم كما يقولون
نحو الجنوب لكن في الواقع ايضا القوات
الروسيه تحاول فتحها جبهات
وجبهات قتال اخرى على طول هذا المحور
الممتد من المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه
للدمباس وحتى زباروجا ونحن نتحدث عن مئات
الكيلومترات حقيقه بالامس كانت محاوله من
جانب القوات الروسيه للهجوم في منطقه
القطاع الاوسط لهذه لخط المواجهه هذا وهذا
ما يعني ان القوات الروسيه تحاول تشتيت
عمل القوات الاوكرانيه هنا على محور
تحديدا شكرا لك